hey back yet Danny as thanks thanks well
panzeri for the update at welcome to the
tech update with Peter Brown who
apparently we're going to talk about
oculus rift and stuff while I play this
awesome Zelda game you look so
futuristic bro this is the future of
video games but apparently that some
news happened while we were on air Peter
literally just walked on set was like
guys I'm gonna blow your mind in about
five seconds and I've been waiting to
have my mind blown Peter this is already
blowing my mind we weren't sure if they
can get blown anymore okay it was pretty
well I think I guess we expected Sony to
announce a headset at one point that was
surprising to me but what's more
shocking is Facebook is buying oculus
what whoa really facebook just putting
the book yet Facebook is by oculus for
four hundred million dollars in cash
whoa 1.6 million billion sorry 1.6
billion in stock options okay what of
facebook stock options paid to homicide
oculus team yeah so roughly two billion
dollar transaction net assets oh my John
karma John happened that just happened
like two minutes hellas Facebook lying
oculus I have no idea John Carmack is
offensive bit by read 12 new spaceships
he sought farmville was crazy before you
thought stalking people was fun in 2d
he's I'd wow I don't even know what to
think about all this that's weird but
okay so yeah that's gonna take me some
time to figure out okay so the big
updates from GDC last week or definitely
vr related yeah sony announced project
Morpheus which is their virtual reality
headset its got like a really space-age
you know looking design going on and
it's used to play games like what
Danny's playing right here which is it
gonna be at on project more Legend of
Zelda you sony have the rights to that
because i'm pretty sure oculus do yeah
and then oculus I guess facebook I don't
know what the company's gonna call down
they they unveiled the their latest
edition of the developer kit devkit to
and that's God 1080p screams you've had
in the past the first four developer kit
it's got a positional tracking with LED
markers hidden behind
plastic and a camera to track all that
so right now Janie can turn his head and
you can see where he's turning but they
can see I like a look at my UI by
looking all right yeah just like in
zelzah yes with the new positional
tracking system what you can do is duck
you can do things like bend and look
around corners and that'll all be taken
care of in the game Danny you just look
so cool right now man you look so
staring at his crotch a second ago
whatever have you looked more elegant I
was I wanted to see if link had it had a
little bit penis pretty party doesn't
he's like maybe not Scott is is that
what that is that's a sword you sure no
I have no idea what you're looking at
Danny you're in a world of your own I
really am but I think like you get him
to either cookie but not actually
swallow any of them it's not a new char
haha so just thank guys in four to five
months or a year's time we all look as
cool as this yeah see I don't know that
it's each sword you friggin bat so
clearly VR is uh so what's happening and
we yeah I mean yes so obviously Sony
Microsoft well Microsoft hasn't had a
peep on the VR front really yet have
they they mentioned that they've been
experimenting with it for a while okay
yeah experimenting with it for a while
yeah we've got the oculus which is now
Facebook situation but you recently had
a debate you know sort of back and forth
with mark Dalton about sort of the
viability of like you know we've seen VR
before there was the Virtual Boy and
then there was other crap that's just
more like he's dead end like geeky tech
scions of like wouldn't it be cool if we
had this it it's not actually that cool
the way we made it but this seems to be
different yeah there are a few key
reasons why i believe vr is here to stay
and in the short term it's going to be
more successful than some of those
devices were you know like the move for
example for example things like the move
in the Wii mode those are sort of
changing the way that you control a game
but you're still playing on a TV and
you're moving a little bit but you're
essentially playing the old games that
you used to just with different controls
right for me vr is totally different it
completely changes the way that you
interact with your environment it's akin
really yeah a day it's it's a much
bigger shift in your gaming habits but
more importantly now to you know
compared to the 80s
the 90s when tech or when VR was pretty
rudimentary and basic and clunky this
big hardware games around that like five
frames a second now we've got stuff did
you say that you then sorry anyway I
thought the umbrellas are here I heard
Peter talk and then I saw the skeleton
yeah it was a skeleton what don't touch
me when I'm ended out of Atlantis don't
do that but yes make the connection and
my mind will be broken forever we've
lost him the dev kits we've got net or
the headsets we've got now are a lot
smaller they're capable of replicating
you know movement in the virtual world
much better even in the past and I think
people are going to be getting a much
better experience at home and it's going
to be fundamentally different than
something just like moving your wrist a
little bit the intro yeah and the stuff
that you get excited about this kind of
tech for is not the first person Zelda
cuz yes that's it gimmick but no Danny
yes it is yeah no that's cool and that's
handsome but uh you know it's good it's
going to take many different factors and
variables to be resolved before I think
VR reaches its potential mm-hmm and and
I am very excited for that and I am
patient my one concern is that too many
people are going to come out right away
with these VR things and and convince
the public that like this is great this
is VR and they're gonna be like this is
okay this is not everything I thought it
was going to be are you worried that
something like steam machines is going
to happen where this just so it's just
proliferation of hardware that the
overall message gets totally lost that's
what I'm getting at I think that that
might be a little bit of an issue but
there are some games out there that
really do kind of capture the best dr
shovelware right so many games are being
ported to VR now after they've been
developed right and what's important is
take a game like Eve Valkyrie for
example made by CCP games that was
designed for VR from the from the
beginning and there's so many things you
have to take into account SATA walkie
are like Zelda was yeah something right
now that plays with the technology that
we have such as Eve Valkyrie where you
don't need to account for the rest of
your body you're really sitting in a
cockpit so you're stationary it's really
just your head tracking and your hands
on a joystick it's not like pretend
you're on a tennis court and swing your
arm it's it's well I guess it is kind of
like that because you can mimic that
motion in your room will exactly it's
not like you know pretend you're walking
through a vast dungeon well Danny's use
injure in a cockpit flying a spaceship
which you
be in this position as well I mean not
have your rank jauntily cross but well
you don't you've never seen me in a
spaceship my necks crossed that cash cab
I mean Danny's moving around with a joy
with a stick right now in a controller
yeah right so to me that's essentially
saying like this is a a rudimentary
virtual reality experience I even
hesitate to call it that personally but
when things start to account for all
those variables and you really do feel
that sense of immersion like I've felt
an eval curry where I actually
anticipate that you know not G forces
but the centripetal force when you pull
back on the flight yoke you know my
brain had been tricked at that point I
actually like I think what I was doing
Jesus Christ a scared the bejesus out of
it and I look forward to more
experiences like that yeah here you
describe your eve valkyrie playtime I
think that's exactly what i want i want
you you want those new experiences and
of course we played flight sims before
you've had the flight stick sitting at
your desk but the experience of sitting
in that cockpit and having some googly
eyed wacko look back at you well you
know what and plus in the start of that
game you'll deal it has one of the best
moments where you're sitting in this
hangar with the sort of red warning
lights flashing like you're about to
take off you put on the rift you put on
your headphones and you're essentially
encased in this little thing like you
would a helmet in an aircraft yeah you
know and just the whole preparation
that's going through your head like care
about to blast through this hangar and
you do and it's you really just get that
sense that you're you're doing what it
is that you're seeing that yeah I love
it and I can't wait for more stuff like
that and so now to reiterate the news
that Peter said at the beginning of the
segment Facebook has purchased oculus
yeah for like two billion it's centrally
and who knows what the hell that means
for the product pipeline for its
consumer you know reach and for its
development focus I mean I can't wait to
talk to the organizers we're gonna
meditate on our for a while get some
interviews and we'll definitely be back
you folks with some some thoughts on
that in the coming days for upcoming
coverage on the world of virtual reality
future video games as state to the case
Malcolm peter brian thank you very much
for coming on the show really appreciate
it will be back
you